I have mostly lived a life dominated by
doubt and fear what are your thoughts on
how I can step into bravery you know I
actually took this question from Twitter
and I answered the question in one word
you've lived a life dominated by doubt
and fear how do you step into bravery
step that's how you step into bravery
step take the step step aggressively
towards your fear and that that step
towards your fear is the step into
bravery because we're per scared of what
we don't know and there's only one way
to learn and to know and that is to
confront that fear you have to step you
have to go and this simple action this
simple attitude it answers so many
questions so many questions how do you
get to the gym every day you step you go
how do you how do you change your diet
you step you go how do you overcome fear
of failure fear of success or fear of
fear itself you step and how do you face
the fear of the unknown your step don't
wait anymore don't think anymore don't
plan anymore don't contemplate anymore
don't make any more excuses or
justifications
don't rationalize anything else no no
and no instead be aggressive take action
now and what is the first action that
you need to take what's the first step
you need to take the first step you need
to take is just that step